explain explain the inspiration behind
the peach
well this is ballet pink oh my fault my
fault okay that's okay ballet pink uh
Dolce Gabbana my stylist Laria urbanati
decided to she had this vision and she
thought that Dolce could put it together
with some Elegance I'll show you some
detail uh this flower
in Polynesian there's a word we term we
have puamana which means strength of a
flower so this represents my daughters
baby we just saw that we just saw that
great social media post where they put a
wig on your head they did your makeup
everything and that's what we do who are
you presenting
uh best animation
I'm with Emily we're paired together you
can talk go ahead you can speak
he's giving you permission to speak
so they were just asking me who's the
most talented most brilliant actor
you've ever worked okay
isn't that right that is 100.
100 right 100 percent
with any other actresses
[Music]